ça c'est moi vous vous demandez sûrement
comment je me suis retrouvé dans cette
situation je vous raconte il y a
quelques années j'étais journaliste et
j'ai décidé d'interviewer Sébastien
Chabal sauf qu'à l'époque Chabal il est
un peu fâché avec les journalistes alors
qu' non comme il veut plus trop faire
d'interview je lui propose un concept
juste pour lui moi je lui pose des
questions provocquantes mais lui il a le
droit de me répondre comme il veut à sa
manière on le rejoint à l'entraînement
avec un de mes collègues pas n'importe
quel collègue vous allez entendre sa
voix à un moment si vous faites
attention dans la vidéo vous me direz si
vous l'avez reconnu question English
vous avez vraiment trop honte de votre
accent ça va
aller et puis un an plus tard comme j'en
avais pas eu assez et que je voulais ma
revanche j'y suis retourné avec deux
collègues mais Chabal il a ramené ses
collègues
[Applaudissements]
aussi